can you tell us why you left Guatemala
podemos usted por que salió de Guatemala
si en primer lugar en mis padres baron
assassin ellos Nick ammonia miss Alma
biggest motivation of why I left is that
my parents were assassinated out of nine
brothers that we were only three of us
remain alive
my entire community was destroyed it was
very important for me to come out with
this information and denounce it
internationally who killed them Ella
here system in Zambia's que me Padre del
hombre que mucho Mucho por la tierra the
army killed my parents particularly my
father was a leader of the community
involved in defending the our cultural
rights and our land rights and because
of that he was persecuted but also
because my land
my village is in what's called a
somewhat of conflict the army began to
harass us more and more to the extent
that the massacres came and the
persecution in that area that was in
1980-81 that was in 1980-81 English in
de you know Chile hey yo Salida ecomony
on en si Nelson setenta yo ello cinta
por que mató vivo mi padre en lombok
Aspen el treinta y no dinero y la yo
cinta yo yo salir computer I had to
leave my own community in 1979 then in
1980 my father was burnt alive in at the
Embassy of Spain in the protest they had
and then in 1981 I had to leave the
country and come to work internationally
and now we have for what's called a
civilian government in Guatemala is is
it really a civilian government Oh a
tenemos un gobierno civilian Guatemala
realmente es un gobierno Sieben see
Enderle hacer eso mismo dia pública
mente cuando
tomó la presidencia que tenía el treinta
y cinco por ciento poder real en los
últimos años en especialmente Alone's de
mayo de este año el ejército given me
president said air so when inaugurated
admitted publicly that he only had 35
percent of power and the situation had
deteriorated to the extent that the
military have opposed him and staged in
an attempted coup on the 11th of May in
which we know that there was 25 points
that were negative by the government
with the officers carrying out the coup
so if said Esso had 35 percent of power
when he came in how much power do you
think he may have left at this moment Oh
Sergei it's a what a mile and le le has
little tiene muchos anos Victoria the
the Army has a long history of
controlling power economically
politically and her and that's not been
altered today so has not changed that
situation on the contrary it is the
presence of sedessa that has served the
military to try to bring a new image try
to stay away from the image of the army
that has persecuted and massacred the
population to the image of a military
that's moving toward democracy but in
the meantime that same military is
planning the new campaigns which are
beginning now against population
companies' case except Amenti las cosas
que realmente guatemala osaki s
inclusive al koh samui básico
en realidad a novo ningún solo
responsively
de las maracas de la repression sobre
todo el aplicación de la tour 2 rango te
mana ki Acedo cast eagle hope we see a
low en tiempo de ser so no solo we can
see that with very basic facts for
instance there has not been one single
person tried and condemned for violation
of Human Rights particularly for
instance for the use of torture which
was widespread not one single case has
been brought up to corridor to trial for
those violations por que antes de que
que tomaron la presidenta Cerezo no
because right before sedessa took office
the military officers passed the law of
self amnesty they themselves proclaim
amnesty to
sabemos esto en una una situación basica
and la vida Humana como se this
situation in something as basic and
fundamental as human rights how are we
not going to doubt what's happening in
the other spheres on the economic social
and political level are you saying that
the repression continues that the
disappearances continue that torture
continues me esta usted diciendo que la
repression continua que la desaparición
s continue a lot or to repent in youa
tal vez in Irma's lejos a según el
procure adorn de derechos humanos del
primero de Octubre al veinte de octubre
de este Me's del mez pasado say
registrar una Guatemala setenta Y Cinco
casos de sequest owes de los setenta Y
Cinco Cinco entire dos de ellos
aparecido sus cadavers in Centro's
públicos in Guatemala just to mention a
go in further dimension one particular
case the prayer of Human Rights Devon
boesemani Guatemala has said that from
the first of October to the 20th of
October there was 75 kidnappings out of
that 52 bodies up here that were taken
to public centers off of the government
of hospitals and morgues there was in
1988 issue singing stay on you c02
Reposado dis just and not even the whole
month of october hace que en realidad en
estos Ultimo's tres meses que c'est un
rose calculus was promedio sin guatemala
agra vido Ascenta casos de sequest rose
y asesinato a poor más de los últimos
resumes in the last three months we have
an average of eighty kidnapped mention
assassinations permit in Guatemala a
parte de la población era de hacer que
se scapa's loc Costra Dora's o la gente
que tratan Tod o contra su su Sabri a
personal nose
including for this percepts and that
doesn't even consider the cases of
attempted kidnapping Frances people that
were wounded or and was managed to flee
or just those simple attempts that did
not succeed
todos estamos de acuerdo en tanto law so
servidores internacionales pero special
meant a loss guatemala texas en que la
violencia ah cracy dou mu n % as
demasiado Anto a partir de loans de mio
a poor Ichabod el de Bantam en toda la
her seat o la demostración de que el
ejército saddest puesto a conducir la
guerra de manera mess violenta en el
país que c'est vida realmente Lozano's
ochenta y OU cinta you know mata mana a
son muy elevados intersession everyone
agrees now not only us looking at her
from inside but also international
observers the desolation in Guatemala
has deteriorated enormously particularly
since the attempted coup of the 11th of
May 88 and since that cool people can
say the dissertation of Human Rights is
today like it was under the period of
president lucas Garcia one of the most
dramatic periods of persecution and yet
you were able as a matter of fact both
of you were able to go back to Guatemala
City during 1988 for at least a brief
period
sin embargo austere meto bahara
a la ciudad wat a milan que saber hombre
de tiempo or en la noche de Ojo ii
cuatro sentimientos policy although we
were received by 500 policemen at the
airport
Angelia esto una and estación a the limb
bahadur de guatemala and the nation's
first time was clarified that our trip
was due initially to an invitation that
we got from the ambassador of what Amala
in Geneva
to the United Nations after a
presentation there we had done and amid
the violation of Human Rights he
launched this invitation it is our
feeling that that invitation was never
for real that always part of propaganda
and part of the rhetoric in terms of
inviting us never expecting us to accept
Juan de nosotros era a Septimus la
invitation a primero lo sabemos las
declaración stltom when we had accepted
and we said that we were going we
initially got a reaction from the high
command of the military saying that we
could not visit the country why should
we go there
including the position of president
siddhis pero para de las reclamaciones
muy fuerte que not only we were hearing
their positions orally in terms of what
they were saying about but also it's
important to point out that that at that
moment is when the death squads or the
so called death squads began putting
bombs in a city as a way of sending us a
message and we must all know the desk
was in Guatemala do not operate in an
independent way but all desk was operate
planned and coordinated by the military
muy Syrio Forel estrous vidas ecoegg
ahmo's la capitale Oh a team Altezza
despues de varias negotiations y ella
ella era
des proportional a la delegation no
estas a sumo squat robot a mistake o's
limos Quattro bottom art echos y la
cantidad de policías que nos espera de
muerte mala era una Claro acto de
intimidation a los interlocutors Janos
otro stem and when we effectively went
to the country the way we will receive
was a disproportionate act of violence
and it was 500 policemen for for what
among us that were returning we
interpreted as a clear act of
intimidation to our return and some of
you were in fact arrested for a while is
that right yell go nose de ustedes
fueron our Estados pro momento a few
more estado dos compañero Rolando
Castillo Montalvo yo Anjali L a decir
que era una una Manifesta sir
our company Roe dr. berlando Castillo
and myself she says we detain at the
airport and this was a clear
intimidation to what we could do because
I've been doing international work for
quite a while and that work is well
known internationally what we have done
in behalf of human rights but it has
been censored inside of what Amala very
few people know about it and this trip
was to be the bigger portunity for us to
go and for her to splain to the people
of what Amala what the international
work has been and clearly there was an
attempt to stop that from happening
and early el es todo apart al dente
siento que nos Dio el gobierno it told
me that intimidation they showed us how
the situation is our trip was a success
after the incidents of intimidation of
the first day but we clearly discovered
that what tamanna does not have the
political space that it says that
there's no space to hold a real serious
national debate on the political
situation and there is no space for
people like us to return enact publicly
and politically the Army and the
government want individuals to return
people individually but when we return
as a team trying to regain our position
in our participation they refused what
is the impact of the recent sale of us
rifles to the Guatemalan government
quail Chris - cuisine impacto de la
Renta venta de pusi lays North
Americanos que se Cho a probable press
also need owes al gobierno de Guatemala
cam3 Medawar yo creo que es muy
peligroso up to now a the supply of
weapons - what mala has come from Israel
obviously United States was involved but
essentially as well was the main
supplier awareness towards knowledge the
fact that is now switching back to
United States we think is a easy
switching policy because although the
United States was involved at the arms
to what am I
for it was involved in directly and I
was trying to keep a rather low profile
all of a sudden the fact the United
States is willing to appear very openly
linked to what Amala military into the
policy that were community marks a worry
it worrisome new period pero mismo
tiempo Primos is party we know that the
United States has its own economic and
political and geopolitical interest in
the region as its presence has been very
much felt in the region but in the case
of Guatemala in particular we felt that
the United States was trying to keep a
low profile contrary to his role in the
rest of the region the ladder
I didn't so look at what in my life and
it is a big perturbation and we don't
quite understand why at this moment from
going from a low profile the United
States is moving to a direct involvement
in the case of what a mom what do you
think US policy toward rahamallah should
be KK days to cabeza la política Estados
Unidos Asiata mala siempre Malabar creo
que el gobierno no te americano que debe
Isetta que los pueblos no solo quat a
man TECO's say no Rispoli Centro
Americanos y latino Americanos a tenemos
derecho de allah here el sistema
política hola I think it's very
important to United States to recognize
the time has come for the
self-determination of the peoples of of
Central America and Latin America una
política de Roma nación Latin spices was
really important as the United States
understand that the peoples in Central
America have the absolute legitimate
right to choose the government and style
and system of government that they
please that is that system of government
they will build through their own
struggle this is the case in the century
not only a lot of Central America but of
all Latin America it's a struggle for
our dignity the dignity of being in the
nations choosing for ourselves what is
our future what is what we want to do a
lower country so much publish
independientes so most Isis a second lap
a political thousand as director the
respect was in the homeless ignore the
imposition a sentence we think the
Paulette policies the United States
should be a policy of respect toward our
peoples and out of imposition yes normal
mental okay Vivian docent Americans
Latino Americans ek en este momento
inclusive la smooches auntie oolitic
inert Americana Ana co-host Amenti
porque no super blue skies
Antonia conciencia de esta situación it
is that policy respect it should
substitute the policy of arbitrariness
an imposition over our peoples because
that's why our struggles our internal
struggles but also struggles against the
mandates of United States because it is
very clear that in Latin America the
population is growing in consciousness
of where the origin of the problems are
and who is actually imposing things on
them generally da da si demos sólo la
ayuda Malita como como la nación de
Estados Unidos in Central America we can
see this with the aspect of military aid
and military assistance that has gone to
war Tamala
supporting obviously the military that
and has an awful things to us but not
only is it in military aid or assistance
that one can I noticed the role of
United States in Guatemala but in what
the model is another phenomena the
massive massive influx of fundamentalist
Christian churches with enormous amount
of money with a very defined
this agenda in your mind we see this as
part of the u.s. tactics as well we see
this as part of that for the US
aggression event in the country and sort
of overshadowed by a veneer of religion
but with a definite political purpose
would you say that the Army and the
government are racist in their attitudes
toward the Indian population dds to
quell ejército el gobierno NC doe
resistance ooh políticas de la población
see and rally a local a a pro Pablo
gobierno es que casi el setenta por
ciento de la población que somos
indígenas hemos sido wreck Lomond Oh
participation political participation
Kaname que nos Ultimo's Ana's y como la
repression la discrimination Acedo tan
grande durante kin en toes a en bottom
Allah no Ava said posible que los
Sabinas en este momento a swearin parte
de la situación political pies las mas
chakras a destiny DoCoMo Nia's completa
las torturous sage a choke on mujeres Y
Nina's embarazada z-- y mas crow LS
todavía que en el resto la población
cosas que si I own a mental Adara sista
discriminatory case a wrestler ha en los
altos de repression del ejército the
answers yes you see the problem for the
government in the Army this moment is
that we the Indian population
she says they represent 70% of the other
people or what Amala all of a sudden are
growing in consciousness about our
rights and our demanding and struggling
and this is something they can
understand because after 500 years of
oppression and discrimination it is
unacceptable for them the law of a
sudden the Indians want to become equals
in this society and demand their full
participation so because of that there
has been a systematic policy repression
and you notice it in the way the army
carried the repression although
repression is generalized in the country
in Indian villages they have really done
harm those things then kill children
kill women we've seen cases of women
that are pregnant being tortured by the
military with a tremendous degree of
ferocity and brutality all this is proof
yes for the army there is a very basic
racist perspective when they commit
genocide in a village in the highlands
in the indian highlands attention
how can peace come to your country
como creo que la paz po de guerre algun
dia - price CL area i've arias alternate
Eva's que mismo polo de Guatemala last
haciendo at this moment the mass
movement of popular organizations and
the church are really pushing very
strongly to force the national dialogue
not only the national value of
reconciliation but also the dialogue
between the government and the insurgent
movement the urng
to achieve peace in the country because
although we tended this national
dialogue is a first step I won't
necessarily bring immediate solutions to
the country we do think it's very
important for step that can begin
pointing to the way to bring about peace
and Rondo alguna Via del conflicting
turn on Guatemala's sobre todo y cuando
el movimiento popular demanda una serie
de respuesta concrete 'as a las
necesidades messer gente de so relevancy
y luego a los efectos del conflict in
turn o son cada vez más altos ha sido el
Norma Norma la Cantina in vidas de Manos
de repression in Segura da de contrôle
militar por lo tanto a [ __ ] gente que
todo lo sectaurs del pollo atomized a
pertinent participant in the solution
the problem especially at this moment
when the popular organizations that the
poor sectors are demanding very concrete
a specific response to their very basic
needs but also because the internal
armed conflict has already caused too
many lives thousands of watermelons
killed and the cost is still escalating
everyone feels the pressure to see and
look
for a solution but a solution that would
incorporate the participation of all
sectors of the watermelon society in
achieving if the Army has effective
power in the country
how would it possibly agree to the kind
of reconciliation that you're talking
about
c/l ejército tiene sa peau dirt an
effective went o el país que se mention
ah como puede hacer se que esto Yaga
Sept Arliss propuestas que tu as a Cho
Seon rally our porque la puedo la la
fuerza del pollo attainment a yo
misremembered adder Solara forces act o
in Guatemala frenzy autumn allah has an
armed internal convoy which is going
challenge in the middle that the popular
organizations in the mass movement is
also growing in terms of strength and
their demands under struggle so it's
very clear that here is an enormous
potential of force coming out from this
population that will go as the ties
between them as they unite they build
those bridges between the different
forces this is an enormous force that
even sedessa could have taken advantage
of so this would have really had a good
intentions in the country he could have
backed his initiatives to transform what
Amala was to support other people but he
didn't he played the role that the
military had assigned for him and became
just an issue illegitimate and we think
it is this strength that will eventually
we can a group of the military I was ok
a irelia solo of Lemelson the sector of
campus in el ejército tiene tanto nila
por ejemplo al caso del cook air
committee Bonilla campus in
por que por que son seis millones de
Guatemala Tico's que necesitan Vivier de
la tierra
por lo tanto LOL prenta con co Mucha
Mucha repression pero sobre todo con
mucho Timor se habla Mo's de todo lo
sectors popularise mess Elkin Demento
de-conflicting terra de cada vez accra
co c vemos los resultados de los
enfrentamientos en las áreas de conflict
o son bastante grande
de Haas Claro que existe un estado de
Araneta bala tierra no declare allah
pero en wotty - es declare allah intent
okay
I saw mass again let's talk about one
specific concrete case the case of the
campesinos why does the army fear so
much the legalization of my organization
to cook the communitarian encompassing
of world because what the mullahs in
agricultural country where you have six
million campesinos so of course the army
is fearful of this amount of people and
the repression to that sector should be
seen as a sign of fear the army
represses because they're afraid of the
strength that the campesino movement is
gone but if you tie that to the struggle
of other sectors of the mass movement
and you tie also this to the increase in
armed struggle to the fact that although
there's not an internationally declared
war but the clearly internally there is
a war and there are war zones in
guatemala the army is getting very
nervous because if you analyze the
amount of casualties they are suffering
they're in a very difficult situation in
those precise zones of conflict eco-mode
each interior mentor really does intento
de Diallo o para llegar a la una so
mission Pacifica a Crayola paso de la
vez a la Justicia Guatemalan that's why
it is to the pressure of the population
demanding a national dialogue that we
think that we can build peace based on
justice in that is only through this
pressure pressure that should come from
inside what the Marla with the
participation of all sectors in this
coalition but also that you go from out
of what them all at the same time
pressure from the international
community to help us achieve the
dialogue on this piece for instance the
international declaration of human
rights it is an important document that
the states what are the human rights of
all the peoples and all the individuals
in the world but those human rights are
only respected not only by the
Declaration which is important but also
by the struggle of the people in each
country that are demanding that those
rights be fulfilled and respected and is
that combination
the international community and the
pressures we can build inside will make
a different yes efore miss button let me
ask you what would happen if Guatemalan
politics were transformed and the left
came to power the way it was in power in
1954 before the coup with the United
States government have anything to fear
from such a government in Guatemala yo
creo que nosotros hoy ellos han sido
tango mil des especialmente moitie mala
en la gran mayoria de la población son
indígenas una cultura tamp Rica con una
una herencia de los myosin tan avanzada
en el pasado pero sobre todo tan vive en
este momento una razón una una dou t
interpreter la vie de pano mana in rally
as he said Aharon nuestros pueblos que
yo se Anna's collegian esa esa forma de
dar continious a forma de vere creo que
ninguna webelo del mundo debería tener
miedo nuestros pueblos inclusive every
end a day at mere Arlo's por por lo
sentimientos tan Manas Eaton buenas
Etienne a nuestra gente I come from a
very humble nation seizes a nation
terrified by Indian peoples and if one
can analyze the richness the importance
that it is for us to base our self in
that Indian identity the Mayan the
tradition of the Mayan culture that
became so great in the past but then
more importantly of the past is that
it's so much alive in the present that
is so much part of our daily life and
what what that means in terms of our
identity our philosophy our way of
seeing things that when we consider the
possibility of selecting our own
government a government that could not
only respect that identity but also
develop it could also give an
alternative to our nation to express
itself as a different nation as a nation
marked by by the tradition in a strong
ethnic identity one does not understand
how any nation in the world could feel
threatened by that
as a matter of fact we think that any
country in the world should feel happy
about this it about the growth of a
country with a particular defined
identity in which our Indian culture
will raise and develop the sort of trust
honor ability and friendship that is
very characteristic of the Indian
peoples Oh c'est que yo creo que la
lucha s'vivon Guatemala
es la combination de la gran necesidad
de ser parte de los que de tener lo
necesario para sobre beer Oh para vivir
en la nación la salud ser parte la
muchas economicus políticas sociales
pero al mismo tiempo es una combination
de la lucha pala ENT da de los pueblos
indígenas porque los in vienna's tenemos
los mismos derechos en nuestra patty yo
no se Futura podamos Desiree ARLA el
rally al es eso sale dos elementos la
lucha economic political social y la
lucha cultural asset a bottom ala l la
lucha el pollo a team al Tico es muy
particular inclusion Centro America pero
también Anabel Internacional OSA muy
particular yo creo que el cambio case
avid RN Guatemala no puede xqe une autre
tiene que ser la combination de ambar
event occasions in the case of what
Amala we feel that we have two different
types of struggle our very legitimate
struggle for our basic needs economic
social and political needs just to
survive economically and to have be able
to feed our families that stroll is
there that struggle is a major immediate
necessity but in a country like ours you
also have to understand the dish another
straw the struggle for the rights of
identity the struggle for the rights of
our people and those struggles have to
be taken into consideration it is for
the indigenous population of what Tamala
extremely important that the all of
breaking the tradition of history at any
given moment they will have the chance
to be equal in that society be full
participants in terms of the identity in
the development of citizens giving a new
character to that nation and also giving
a new alternative of survival for that
rich culture